dans sa maison de la rivière du mât noël
d'affi vivre dans les moindres recoins
toutes sortes d'objets qu'elle habille
avec des rubans de toutes les couleurs
de son imagination et sa dextérité
naissent des décorations qui ont pour
effet de donner à chaque pièce un air de
fête
plus pratique cette maman de quatre
enfants créent également des objets à
partir d'éléments de récupération dont
la transformation vous étonnera créé
s'occuper noël dont nous parle d'un
savoir faire qu'elle n'a pu apprendre
sur les bancs de l'école
le no money des mois toujours inventer
mais sûrement pour le tricot et manquait
toujours un petit peu à l'école on en
parle trop loin à l'école ben moi le
marbre quatre européennes mais c'est une
classe que terre comme un atelier faire
pour la couture
après côté elle avait appris à tricoter
a fait un petit peu les rosaces blanc
jusqu'à maintenant mais voit
provisionnent la déside étudiants sait
avec quelle manière de travailler que le
fils c'est le cadeau le ruban la rumba
cac dopé la confiance et commence son
travail
ben parce que si je marchais avant avait
des petites poupées la lame diktat en
l'essayant peut-être mon amie des
enfants aussi si vous voyez le petit peu
défriser mais a préféré désir il faut
pas perdre espoir donc continuer le
travail
je crois qu'on vient comme ça on a autre
chose à faire mais des pins quand il
tout en même temps il ya beaucoup
d'objets de récupération
ah oui à tout va les bouquetins ya plein
de choses et bouteilles cela passe sous
la main quoi d'accord le petit paul
yarrow les voir les tutelles vont
apprendre oui des boîtes de cassoulet
oui des boîtes grains à bois décorés et
ça servirait à quoi servent pour mettre
tes crayons dessus un bureau on a des
très bons et un porte crayons quoi des
stylos tout c'est du bouquet aussi nous
sommes en un petit bouquet comme tout
prix artificielle parce que ça c'est des
boîtes qui rouille pas mettre le foin
sec et ses deux boîtes différentes sinon
c'est le même mais seulement le travail
est différent
ou quand ce n'est pas le même
pour travailler pareil et vous propose
huit anciens cette voie là où les
humains de pareilles je pense un petit
peu plus compliqué pour et vos travaux
travaux ne sont pas assez connus n'ont
pas connu du tout est ce que c'est ça
c'est un récupération ça va tellement
vite qu'on va retrouver
oui alors marc pinta type est abîmée la
mettre en peinture des dents et moi
travaillons au jeu des siens
d'accord mais toujours avec monsieur
cadeau est censé le maintien j'en viens
oui ça c'est le vampire est là il vous
faut quoi comme la thèse à la main au
csa pour couvrir le brochet le coaching
voilà c'est comme décoration
alors si quelqu'un mais c'est ma vidéo
alors qu'est ce qui vous fait le plus
souvent le reflet tout quoi ça se
passait dans l'idée c'est pour vendre ou
parfums que dans les quelques âmes est
pas tout
tout commence à arriver à placer
commence à penser bouche à oreille
après avoir évolué dans le calcul
quelque chose de la personne il demande
ça a lâché que ça ben hilli chez une
personne c'est bouche à oreille combien
de temps vous faudra vous savez fond de
moi 2 jours 2 2 2 me c'est toujours en
rouge ben oui c'est déjà ça n'est pas
facile à tricoter parce qu'il faut bien
tenir
oui c'est la bouteille de glisser ça
sert à quoi c'est un objet de décoration
ou est-ce qu'il ya possibilité
d'utiliser la bouteille c'est que
décoration uniquement des migrations
mais amman a vraiment vrai d'après la
romance travailler comme ça je confonds
pas profonde intimité peau et la découpe
ce fait comment pour avoir de la découpe
c'est pareil pendant l'heure où les
choses là comme ça peut découvrir des
paniers pour un mariage latéraux
millions c'est un magnifique ronis et
tout ça c'est des idées et ça c'est
l'effet à base il faut le calendrier les
vieux calendriers pour mettre dessus
avant de mettre le calendrier dessus et
après pour gary travail avec le ruban
adhésif et ça vous invite à des
commandes tant pour fassent pas nul a
démissionné
ah oui là comme ça comme c'est pour tous
et pour mettre un petit quelque chose de
trop comme un héros m'arranger avec un
bouchon liège au tire-bouchon et quand
vous commencez votre travail justement
ce que vous commencez à réaliser par les
tiges vous commencez avec des feuilles
vous faites comme ça vous vient déjà
c'est une complication parce qu'il faut
mesurer compter comme ça séparer les les
films ou après il faut coller aménagé
travailleurs c'est beaucoup de travail
ah oui tu as tous les découpages ces
découpages que les plus difficiles vous
fermez toutes les petits paniers ou des
compagnes et plein de choses quoi
d'accord et l'espagne et raconte année
un petit peu comme l'a justement il y en
a une idée le petit peu yahoo dit qu'on
veut enfin l'alignement jeudi à watts et
les petits pots et elle peut servir
quelque chose il m'a décidé de faire les
petits pots pour le baptême bonne chose
nous concéder comment ben là il faut
prendre un petit panier comme ça
d'accord déjà il faut couper le tour
et ça ne pouvait plus compliqué alors
cela découper vos goûts et les couleurs
il faut attacher le silence là mais le
trait sur lot de manière à la baignade
au firmament fait comme ça au moins le
plus vite et on commence toujours par un
attaché la lance ah oui parce que si on
travaille dessus
la guerre puis il ya bien aussi il ya vu
le film
enfin bon c'est comme ça peut être doté
qui mais après
sand et oui monique est passable des
petites ou le marité style en france
c'est pas trop grand chose sur mon lit
chez les indiens bien décoré mais moins
le montant doit commencer à voir une
maison pour des cours et c'était mon
rêve et mon rêve à réaliser
mais seulement il faudra aller le ruban
parce que sans ça y est pas un travail
il faut toujours à couper la même
grandeur parce que ce sont des petits
paliers top ce travail quand on a
commencé on ne peut pas le lâcher ou il
faut généraliser
et puis pour faire plus vite ou fait une
grande chaîne
voilà pour les enfants la sphère
couleurs communion dans appel bouazza la
voilà en fait aux enfants chacun en
espagne à côté d'enfants y avait à
braver au moins trente trente deux 32
plus ces dames 4 6 mais t'es fier même
instant filiale sas et la finition
oui ça c'est la finition il n'est pas là
plusieurs manières là d'essayer avec un
petit morceau
bush dont sept films ou bien go il peut
mettre aussi comme s'adresser c'est sa
plus vite
et ça c'est la boîte que mal appris à
travailler dessus comme ça le bas valais
les dents oui mais après benjamin fils
de faire travailler sur le toit faisait
pas douter pendant des branches
j'ai pris comme un temps pour
confectionner son budget mais trois
jours parce que vit avec eux le simon
foley cet accord avec le bois vers les
taux bas au moins trois joie est ce que
ça vous arrive de d'exposer vos sujets
oui on a fait deux fois exposition à
saint-andré n'a en effet pas et il nous
fait la semaine bleue à la mema vite
pour aider les choses comme les non
seulement on avait plutôt les bouteilles
tricoter comme ça et les gens pour ça
devait y faire quelque chose n'hésite
pas de montrer notre savoir-faire déjà
il faut savoir c'est quoi et surtout il
est beaucoup pensent que les mamans elle
a toujours des petits soucis quoi et ça
c'est des choses que oublie la betty
quotidien allant au but c'était un
séchage groupe i